good morning john so i'm a bit of a
science guy
which i love i love the job i love the
science i love learning new things about
the world
but it is entirely possible to have too
much
faith in the existing body of
scientifically supported knowledge like
if you take all that information and you
treat it as gospel
guess what that is deeply unscientific
it's easy to forget
that we don't know most things like the
things that we do know we have a pretty
good idea
now there are some of those things that
we do know that might turn out to be a
little bit wrong or all the way wrong
it's pretty unlikely but mostly what we
have is stuff that we just don't know
about at all
many times in history people have had
diseases that doctors were like you
don't have a disease and then it turned
out they just didn't know about that
disease that is happening in doctor's
offices right
now like that's a limitation that we
have but i want to talk about a thing
that bugs me
when faced with the reality of the
fallibility of scientific knowledge
a lot of people will go looking for
alternatives and those alternatives
might be valuable but they exist outside
of the
constraints of science and so they can
and often do kind of just claim stuff
and they tend to claim things that kind
of vibe with people's
perspectives and emotions rather than
vibing with reality we need to be on the
lookout for when different sets of rules
are being applied to different systems
in our guts we're going to be much more
frustrated when science gets something
wrong
because our society does rightfully
herald its accuracy and also because of
that
science has a lot of power in our
society when alternatives are wrong
though
it's a little bit like when afc
wimbledon loses it's like
well yeah that happens i'm sorry but in
order to be scientifically supported
information has to exist inside of some
really specific and pretty harsh
constraints whereas alternatives can
kind of claim whatever
that doesn't mean that they're always
wrong it just means that
they are much more likely to be wrong
that's what the constraints of science
do they make information
much more likely to be true so let's do
an example of the constraints of science
ivermectin is not an effective treatment
for cova but this time next year
it might be that ivormectin is an
effective treatment for coving but how
could the same drug be both effective
and not effective depending on the year
well the most recent meta analysis of
ivermectin shows that when you look at
randomized control trials only
most of them show no effect some show
positive effects some show negative
effects but there's also a really big
well-designed study being done right now
in england that will give us a lot more
good data
and it's a good idea to run that study
because several observational trials
that were not randomized or
placebo-controlled have shown strong
positive effects so the fda can't
suggest that doctors prescribe
ivermectin for covid because within the
constraints of science
there is no evidence that it works on
the other hand anyone in the world can
get on cable news
and shout that the fda is holding
ivermectin back from patients who are
needlessly suffering because they are
not operating under the same constraint
being wrong on cable news isn't illegal
in fact
it appears to be encouraged now there
are also people who will hear the fda
say
ivermectin is not an effective treatment
for kovid and they will turn that into
ivermectin is bad and dangerous and you
want to give my grandma horse dewormer
and that is not a problem of
over trusting science that is a problem
of misunderstanding science this is one
of the
billions of things that we don't know
yet
but we are using science to find out so
let's do the research let's do it
properly let's do it carefully and in
the meantime
let's try and keep people from taking
their dog's heartworm medication
if we don't do this methodically we
might end up trusting data that is later
proven to be false as happened
with the most widely publicized papers
showing ivermectin's efficacy which was
recently retracted so yes
you can put too much faith in science is
not always right
and if we all thought it was always
right it would stop progressing
because science is not a set of facts
it's not an ideology
it is just a system that humans created
that is really really good at uncovering
truth john
i'll see you on tuesday